[Musique]
à votre avis comment sont les jeunes de
15 ans qui tous différents tous genres
madame à votre avis comment et la jeune
fille de 15 ans 1975
très bien c'est à dire ben je la trouve
très bien parce que enfin pour moi je
parle un peu pour mes filles elles
continuent leurs études moi je les
trouve très équilibrés sont très bien et
jeune fille casion 19,75 je pense
qu'elle est volage frivole elle pense
que la bagatelle enfin pour moi c'est ça
j'ai eu 15 ans il ya quatre ans je me
souviens pas tellement mais actuellement
je crois que tout superficiel
enfin je crois que c'est la crétion 15
ans et comment voyez-vous la jeune fille
de 15 ans en 1975 j'ai évidemment pour
un homme de mon âge il l'a comparé à ce
que les camarades de classe avaient
quand avait 15 ans également
je crois que la jeune fille est assez
nantis par la vie à l'heure actuelle est
ce que les jeunes de 15 ans ne pense
qu'aux filles oh non pas des tours pense
à beaucoup de choses
les jeunes ou les garçons jeunes jeunes
les jeunes garçons
chn non et jeunes filles aux garçons
bon la jeune fille de 15 ans ne pense
qu'aux garçons
non elle y pense quand même on vous la
jeune fille jade est non c'est exact je
crois oui elle aime sortir fai alice et
de désobéir à ses parents souvent et
essayer de sortir contre leur gré pour
aller lire trouvait justement fin je
pense qu'aux garçons certaines
certainement du sens quasi c'est de
sortir de leur ghetto famille familiale
elle s'est un peu de s'extérioriser
non la plupart oui paris aussi je ne
crois pas vous avez quel âge tout est de
14 euros ce à quoi vous pensez voix la
musique je crois ce musée c'est quoi
s'amuser
je dois faire à faire des choses qui
nous font plaisir la jeune fille de 15
ans ne pense qu'à la moto non patin à
glace natation c'est vrai aussi
et comment vous expliquer cette
attirance
je peux pas vous dire enfin la grosseur
les styles al sabri
ces gros satire est ce que vous pensez
qu'un garçon qui a une belle moto
draguera plus une fille de 15 ans
qu'elle garde son sang moto c'est omar
se défendre ça dépend le charme du
garçon à la moto certainement ce quelque
chose de nouveau pour elle alors à vos
fait pas tout oui certaines foxton mode
alors on s'y plier cet âge-là je suis
modeste église soi même je le crois pas
sur cela pas sur celle là pourquoi
au-dessus 125 250 m avec ça on drague
pas non la jeune fille de 15 ans fait
déjà l'amour
oh non je ne crois pas je prends
derrière tout le temps mais en fait je
crois pas alors là ça je ne sais pas
alors ça je peux pas vous répondre
même même nom au bas âge puis ben oui ça
dépend quelle fille ses dépenses la
fille quand tombe bien incertaine qui le
font et ça me semble être une femme j'en
connais mais pas tellement pas la
majorité veut dire en plus ouais c'est
vrai ils n'ont pas les dames la jeune
fille de 15 ans ne pense qu'à danser à
s'amuser
non non le sport ce qu'une notation
patin à glace vraiment insisté sur le
danger le s'amuse mais ne pense pas que
ça ça dépend d'elle ça dépend de l'état
jeune fille la jeune fille de 15 ans
désire un jour se marier au banc bien
sûr le mariage est encore une notion
hommage et moi enfin je préfèrerais
qu'elles vivent un peu chanceux mariés
puissent amener aussi heureux enfin bref
j'ai foncé voudront se marier normes et
fifres livre lui être libre de tabou de
tous les tabous qui existe
s'ils veulent se caser directement je
crois il pense déjà à se marier sont
plus qu ils sont pressés déjà elles
veulent un métier plus tard oui je sais
qu'ils veulent tout le travail
vous avez 17 ans comment étiez-vous il
ya deux ans c'était horrible c'est à
dire c'est vrai on pense qu'un garçon
c'est vrai c'est la seule chose qui nous
attire maintenant après ça passe je
pense ça m'a passé finalement mais à 15
ans on a envie de sortir désobéir aux
parents d'aller dans les boums en
cachette
c'est souvent ça et à quoi on pense à 17
à 17
on pense aux études c'est mon cas
[Musique]